[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: THAT MAKES SENSE.
HAPPY THURSDAY EVERYONE.
WHEN I WAS A KID WE HAD A FEW
THINGS WE WERE SCARED OF.
THE BRITISH ARMY,
TUBERCULOSIS -- I KID, I'M NOT
THAT OLD.
WE ALL HAD THE SAME FEARS, THERE
WAS THE BOOGIE MAN HIDING IN
YOUR CLOSET UNDER YOUR BED TO.
YOU NEVER REALLY KNEW WHAT HE
LOOKED LIKE WHAT YOU IT WAS
THIS.
[LAUGHTER]
I HAD A REALLY WIDE CLOSET.
THERE WAS THE THREAT OF NUCLEAR
WAR, KIDNAPPERS WHO KEPT THE
BACK OF MILK CARTONS FILLED WITH
INTERESTING BREAKFAST READING
MATERIAL.
GREAT WHITE SHARKS, QUICKSAND,
REMEMBER QUICKSAND?
WE WOULD BE BUSY LOOKING OUT FOR
QUICKSAND AND THEN WE GET HIT BY
A DRUNK DRIVER.
[LAUGHTER]
ALSO THERE WERE CULTS LIKE THE
MANSON FAMILY AND THEY WERE NOT
MUCH OF A FAMILY.
I'M GLAD I GOT OUT OF THAT
EARLY.
AT HIS EIGHT FEARS, SOME ARE NOT
REAL OTHERS MOSTLY OVERBLOWN.
I ENVY THE KIDS TODAY NOT JUST
BECAUSE THEY ARE TALLER, THEY
JUST HAVE MUCH MORE TO BE SCARED
OF.
THERE IS THIS, AND THIS.
AND THIS.
BUT WORSE, THE STREETS WERE
FILLED WITH NIGHTMARISH
CHARACTERS THAT WOULD MAKE
FREDDY KRUEGER CALL ON HUBER
INSTEAD OF WALKING THE FOUR
BLOCKS HOME.
THERE'S A MENTALLY ILL AND
CRIMINALLY DERANGED TO ROAM THE
STREETS, THANK GOD FOR THAT OR
WE WOULD HAVE NO LIVE AUDIENCE
MEMBERS TONIGHT.
THAT IS A JAB AT YOU GUYS.
THERE'S ALSO JUNKIES LAYING
RIGHT IN YOUR PATH.
IT'S AWKWARD WHEN THEY ASK FOR
AUTOGRAPHS ESPECIALLY WHEN I
ONCE DATED THEM.
YOU HAVE HOMELESS USING YOUR
STOOP AS A BATHROOM AND THEY
NEVER, EVER CLEAN UP.
PLUS THEY GIVE LOUSY DIRECTIONS.
NEVER ASK I DID ONCE AND
CHRIS WALLACE THREW UP ALL OVER
ME.
HOLLYWOOD CONCOCTS POINTLESS
DYSTOPIAN LIKE HANDMAID'S TALE
WE ARE LIVING THE REAL THING.
SAVE YOURSELF SOME MONEY AND
CANCEL NETFLIX GO FOR A WALK
AFTER DARK YOU WILL BECOME THE
MAIN CHARACTER IN PART OF A
MURDER MYSTERY BY 11:00 P.M.
ACCORDING TO "THE NEW YORK POST"
OF THE PAPER OWNED BY OUR PARENT
COMPANY, NEW YORK CITY KIDS ARE
NOW IN THERAPY DUE TO A CONSTANT
STATE OF PANIC.
JUST WHAT NYC NEEDS A WHOLE
GENERATION OF WOODY ALLENS.
THE FEAR IS RATIONAL, THE
HOMELESS, CRIME, DRUGS,
ANTHONY WEINER.
STILL HERE, THAT IS JUST INSIDE
THE SANDBOX AT PRE-K.
IN NYC CHILDREN ARE BEING
TRAUMATIZED BY REAL HORRORS THAT
LEAVE PERMANENT SCARS.
FUNNELING THOUSANDS OF THE
HOMELESS INTO CITY HOTELS AND
NOT JUST MOTEL 6.
UNPROVOKED CRIMES HAVE EXPLODED,
NOT TO MENTION ROOM SERVICE IS
IMPOSSIBLE TO GET IN UNDER TWO
HOURS.
TRY TO ORDER THAT METH?
OLD MAN.
AT ESTATE BILL REFORM WHICH
RELEASED TONS OF VILE THUGS, THE
ONLY PEOPLE LEFT IN AMERICA'S
JAILS ARE THOSE WHO STOLE OFFICE
SUPPLIES ON JANUARY 6TH.
WE DECRIMINALIZED SIDEWALK
CAMPING, HAND HANDLING AND
SHOOTING UP IN PUBLIC.
THE RESULT?
A LIBERAL'S DREAM COME TRUE.
WE ARE ALL EQUAL AND ABJECT
MISERY.
MAJOR CRIMES ARE UP ALL OVER,
ROBBERIES ARE UP 57%.
THERE HAVE BEEN TEN MURDERS
ALONE SO FAR IN JUST THREE
PRECINCTS THIS YEAR.
DOUBLED THE NUMBER DURING THE
SAME PERIOD LAST YEAR AND THEY
HAPPENED WHEN CAT WAS OUT OF
TOWN AND WE CAN'T BLAME HER.
ACCORDING TO HUMAN RESOURCES WE
CAN'T BLAME HER ALTHOUGH ONE OF
THE BODIES WAS COVERED UP UNDER
A PILE OF HAIR EXTENSIONS.
IN THE OLD DAYS IF YOU WANTED TO
SEE THE SHOW THE FULL MONTY USED
TO BUY TICKETS FOR BROADWAY.
NOW YOU GET THE FULL MONTY FROM
THE THREE HOMELESS GUYS IN FRONT
OF OUR BUILDING.
CITY PARENTS ARE SENDING THEIR
KIDS TO THERAPISTS BECAUSE IT
TAKES A PROFESSIONAL TO SAY HOW
DOES SEEING A NAKED MAN HARASS
YOU MAKE YOU FEEL?
AT LEAST THEY ARE DOING
SOMETHING, REALLY THEY SHOULD DO
MORE.
WHY DON'T YOU JUST LEAVE?
IS THAT THE RIGHT THING TO DO?
I GET IT, WE LOVE OUR KIDS BUT
NOT IF IT MEANS GIVING UP OUR
SEASON TICKETS TO THE
METROPOLITAN OPERA OR MISSING
THE GAY PRIDE PARADE EVERY YEAR.
WHAT KIND OF ROOMS DO YOU TAKE
US FOR?
I QUESTION THEIR JUDGMENT BUT
THEY ALREADY VOTE DEMOCRAT.
IT'S EASY FOR ME TO SAY I GOT NO
KIDS BUT YOU CAN NO LONGER
RELAXED THINKING IT'S JUST A
THOUGHT ON SUBPRIME.
IT'S RUSSIAN ROULETTE FOR ALL OF
US, WE ARE ALL IN THE BARREL.
KIDS GET TO SEE THE BOOGIE MAN
EVERY DAY ON THE WAY TO CLASS,
ON THE SUBWAY.
I UNDERSTAND SOLDIERS COMING
HOME FROM WAR SUFFERING PTSD
FROM WHAT THEY SAW BUT FOURTH
AND FIFTH GRADERS COMING HOME
FROM SCHOOL.
SOME FAMILIES ARE SMARTLY
LEAVING THEM ACCORDING TO A
RECENT HEAD COUNT THEY SAW 10%
DROP IN KIDS UNDER FIVE TREND
SINCE 2019 AND NOT ALL OF THAT
CAN BE ATTRIBUTED TO ERECTILE
DYSFUNCTION CAUSED BY LIZZO.
BUT SOMEONE TO POINTED OUT.
PUBLIC SCHOOL ENROLLMENT HAS
DROPPED BY 73,000 SINCE THE
PANDEMIC.
WHO KNOWS, THEY MAY FINALLY
LEARN SOMETHING?
MORE AND MORE IT'S WOMEN WHO
BECOME THE VICTIMS, A RECENT ONE
WAS A YOUNG MOTHER OF FIVE WHO
WAS BRUTALLY BEATEN BY A
TRANSIENT FREAK.
TALK ABOUT A CHANGE IN SOCIETY
USED TO BE WOMEN AND CHILDREN
FIRST WHEN IT CAME TO AVOIDING
SUFFERING.
NOW IT'S GET THEM TO THE FRONT
LINES.
I GUESS YOU COULD SAY THAT'S THE
ONLY EQUITY DEMOCRATS HAVE
ACTUALLY DELIVERED.
LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT'S GUESTS!
SHE'S NEVER DEPRESSED BECAUSE
SHE'S ALWAYS LOOKING UP, COHOST
OF AMERICA'S NEWSROOM AND THE
FIVE, DANA PERINO.
[APPLAUSE]
HE'S THE STAR OF THE NEW COMEDY
SPECIAL DON'T QUIT YOUR DAY JOB,
ACTOR, WRITER, COMEDIAN JAMIE
LISSOW!
[APPLAUSE]
HER LAUGH DOUBLES AS A HYENAS
MATING CALL, FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR KAT TIMPF.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
AND HE USES A PARKING METER AS A
Q-TIP, MY MASSIVE SIDEKICK AND
WORLD N.W.A. CHAMPION TYRUS!
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
WELCOME BACK.
>> GOOD TO BE HERE.
>> I WOULDN'T PRESUME THAT YET.
ASSUMING YOUR KIDS STILL SPEAK
TO YOU WOULD YOU EVER MOVE HERE
WITH CHILDREN IF YOU HAD A GREAT
CAREER CHANGE?
IF WE WERE TO OFFER YOU AN
AMAZING GIG FOR ZILLIONS OF
DOLLARS.
>> FOR ZILLIONS I WOULD DO IT.
I DIDN'T EVEN KNOW THAT WAS
REAL.
I WOULD NOT MOVE HERE WITH MY
KIDS, IT'S FRIGHTENING.
TO WIN THE MORNING LAST NIGHT I
WAS AT THE HOTEL I WANTED TO GO
FOR A WALK AND I LEFT MY HOTEL
AND IMMEDIATELY WENT BACK INSIDE
TO.
THIS IS DANGEROUS!
WHAT IS GOING ON IN NEW YORK?
I GET A LOT OF IT IS HAPPENING
IN HELL'S KITCHEN -- IT IS
CALLED'S KITCHEN.
YOU CAN'T BE SURPRISED.
CAN YOU BELIEVE WHAT'S HAPPENING
IN SATAN'S HOLE?
I JUST CAN'T BELIEVE IT.
[LAUGHTER]
SOME OF THE HOMELESS PEOPLE I
ENJOY MORE THAN OTHERS, I LIKE
ONE WITH THE TALENT.
I SAW THIS GUY BEING A STATUE,
NOT MOVING AT ALL AND HE'S
MAKING ALL THIS MONEY FOR NOT
MOVING.
I WALKED ABOUT HALF MILE DOWN
THE ROAD AND THERE WAS ANOTHER
HOMELESS GUY JUMPING UP AND
DOWN, SHAKING A COP AN END I WAS
LIKE IF YOU JUST HOLD STILL --
[LAUGHTER]
YOU ARE WORKING WAY TOO HARD.
I DON'T THINK I WOULD MOVE HERE
WITH MY KIDS RIGHT NOW.
>> Greg: THERE YOU GO.
TYRUS, WHAT KIND OF ADVICE WOULD
YOU GIVE -- LET'S SAY YOU HAD TO
LIVE HERE, WHAT ADVICE WOULD YOU
GIVE YOUR KIDS?
>> I WOULD START WITH THE
PARENTS, WE HAVE TO PARENT UP.
YOU HAVE TO GET OFF YOUR PHONE,
BE VIGILANT, HAVE CONVERSATIONS
WITH YOUR KIDS, SIT THEM DOWN, I
GREW UP IN A ROUGH NEIGHBORHOOD.
I KNEW WHAT TO DO WHEN SOMEBODY
BAD CAME AROUND.
WHAT IS HAPPENING IS WE ARE
HEARING MY CHILD -- WHAT ARE YOU
DOING ABOUT IT?
NOT ALL OF US CAN LEAVE.
SOME OF US HAVE TO BEAR WITH IT
IN THE BEST WAY TO DO THAT IS BY
HAVING TOUGH CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
YOUR KIDS ABOUT LIFE LESSONS.
IF HE DESCRIBED HIM AS THE
BOOGIE MAN AND YOU DON'T KNOW
WHERE HE COMES FROM AND THE KIDS
DON'T QUITE GET IT -- IF YOU SIT
THEM DOWN IT'S TOUGH TO TELL AN
8-YEAR-OLD THAT THIS IS WHAT
HAPPENS WITH SUBSTANCE ABUSE AND
THIS IS WHAT HAPPENS WHEN PEOPLE
DON'T TAKE CARE OF THEMSELVES.
IT'S GOING TO BE BUT WHY, CAN'T
WE GIVE THEM A HUG TO?
AND YOU HAVE TO EXPLAIN TO THEM
BECAUSE OF HAD THESE
CONVERSATIONS IT'S NOT FUN AND
YOU HAVE TO KEEP BRINGING IT UP
AND YOU HAVE TO PRACTICE,
PRACTICE WITH MY KIDS ALL THE
TIME WHAT TO DO IF A STRANGER
COMES UP TO YOU AND ONE OF THE
RULES WE LIVE BY IS --
SCIENTIFICALLY, AND KIDNAPPERS
USUALLY LIKE INNOCENT CHILDREN.
MY KIDS IF SOMEBODY WALKS UP TO
THEM THEY DON'T KNOW THEY WILL
BE LIKE WHAT DO YOU WANT TO DO?
[LAUGHTER]
WE PRACTICE THIS.
UNFORTUNATELY, SOMETIMES IT GOES
A LITTLE AWRY.
MY DAUGHTER I GOT HER A PHONE
BECAUSE I'M A FACE TIME DAD, ALL
MY KIDS HAVE PHONES WE DO FACE
TIME TO DO HOMEWORK AND STUFF.
SHE GOT A RANDOM MESSAGE FROM
AT&T WELCOMING HER TO HER NEW
PHONE.
THE OPERATOR WHO SENT THE
MESSAGE GOT [BLEEP] DON'T YOU
EVER CALL MY PHONE AGAIN I'M
GOING TO KILL YOU.
AFTER I EXPLAINED IT TO HER MOM
IN THE COURT THEY WERE GOOD WITH
IT.
YOU GOT TO EDUCATE YOUR KIDS.
>> Greg: THAT EXPLAINS A LOT
OF THE RESPONSES TO ME WHEN I'M
IN THE GREEN ROOM.
>> YES.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: THIS LEADS TO A VERY
INTERESTING OBSERVATION OR
EPIPHANY IF YOU WILL.
CHILDREN IN A WEIRD WAY THEY ARE
LIKE LIBERALS IT IN THE SENSE
THEY HAVE EMPATHY WITHOUT
WISDOM.
WHEN YOU'RE WALKING DOWN THE
STREET WITH A KID AND THE KID
SAYS WHY DIDN'T YOU THAT MAN
MONEY?
HE HAS A LITTLE DOG AND YOU'RE
LIKE BECAUSE THE MONEY ISN'T
GOING TO THE LITTLE DOG, IT GOES
TO -- IT GOES INSIDE HIS ARM AND
THAT HE GETS REALLY HIGH AND
THEN HE STEALS THINGS.
CHILDREN IN A WEIRD WAY THEY ARE
NOT THERE YET.
THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON.
DO YOU EVER WORRY ABOUT THIS
HAPPENING TO YOUR DOG?
>> I DO WORRY ABOUT ONE OF THEM
ATTACKING PERCY.
I THINK ONE OF THE THINGS IS
PEOPLE HAVE TO START LIVING IN
THE REAL WORLD.
THE NEW YORK THAT YOU LOVED, THE
NEW YORK THAT YOU GREW UP WITH
OR THE NEW YORK YOU MOVED HERE
FOR DURING THE RUDY GIULIANI
YEARS, THAT NEW YORK IS NO
LONGER HERE.
THERE IS THIS WISHFUL THINKING
THAT YOU THINK IT'S GOING TO GET
BETTER.
I DON'T SEE HOW IT GETS BETTER
I'M USUALLY A PRETTY OPTIMISTIC
PERSON.
>> Greg: YOU MADE A BOOK
CALLED THINGS ARE GOING TO BE
OKAY!
[LAUGHTER]
>> UNLESS YOU GO TO NEW YORK.
>> EVERYTHING WILL BE OKAY IF
YOU MAKE SMART DECISIONS.
ONE OF THE DECISIONS PEOPLE ARE
HAVING TO MAKE IS -- THEY CAN'T
ALL LEAVE.
WHAT CAN YOU DO TO TAKE THE
INNOCENCE OF YOUR CHILDREN THAT
YOU LOVE BUT MAKE SURE THEY ARE
ALSO GOING TO BE SAFE.
THE VIOLENCE IS SO RANDOM, IT'S
RANDOM EVERYWHERE.
I AM A LITTLE BIT NERVOUS NOT SO
MUCH FOR PERCY BUT SOMETIMES YOU
THINK IF YOU HAVE A DOG YOU WILL
BE SAFER, THERE IS THAT.
I THINK I WOULD BE A LOT MORE
SAFE IF TYRUS CAN TEACH ME HOW
TO SAY THAT LIKE YOUR DAUGHTER
SAYS THAT.
>> I GOT YOU.
>> Greg: DON'T PRETEND LIKE
YOU DON'T SWEAR WE HAVE FILM
PROOF OF THAT WHICH I WOULD CALL
UP AN HOUR BUT I DON'T HAVE IT
ON HAND.
>> IT'S ALLIN PRESENTATION.
I GOT YOUR.
>> I CAN'T EVEN BEGIN TO SAY IT.
>> Greg: WE ARE BOTH LUCKY
BEING SMALL, USUALLY A LOT OF
THE HOMELESS PEOPLE ARE TALLER
THAN ME.
THEY LOOK RIGHT PAST ME.
IT'S ONE OF THOSE GREAT THINGS.
>> HOMELESS PEOPLE THERE LIKE
WHO IS THE BIGGEST GUY?
>> IF THAT WAS THE CASE I WOULD
COME IN TO WORK GO WHEN YOU
WOULD NOT BELIEVE WHAT HAPPENED.
>> Greg: YOU WALKED QUITE AWAY
FROM THE WEST SIDE OVER.
DO YOU THINK THE CITY IS
IRRETRIEVABLE.
THAT IS THE MOST PESSIMISTIC
THING I'VE EVER HEARD FROM DANA.
>> I THINK PROBABLY, WE ALL
STILL LIVE HERE.
WHY DO YOU LIVE HERE?
WE ALL DO.
>> Greg: WE HAVE TO WORK HERE.
>> SOMETIMES THEY ARE MEAN.
THE PANDEMIC YOU REMEMBER WHEN
ALL THERE WAS TO DO WAS WALK?
MY HUSBAND AND I WERE WALKING
AROUND AND SOME HOMELESS GUY
STARTED SHOUTING AT HIM -- IT
WAS THE PANDEMIC I LOOKED REALLY
BAD AND WE ALL LOOKED UGLY THEN.
HE STARTED SHOUTING LIKE I BET
YOU WISH YOU KNEW TEN YEARS AGO
SHE WOULD LIKE THIS TEN YEARS
LATER.
[LAUGHTER]
I WAS LIKE I'M ONLY 32!
31 -- I FORGET TO.
THOSE WERE SOME TOUGH TIMES.
I WENT HOME AND I TOOK A SHOWER
GO THAT ACTUALLY HELPS.
>> Greg: I THINK THAT IS A
POSITIVE REACTION FROM A
HOMELESS PERSON.
>> I SHOULD'VE GIVEN HIM MONEY,
I WONDER IF HE'S STILL ALIVE.
>> YOU MADE ME THINK HOMELESS
GUY WITH A DOG, YOU HAVE TO FEEL
BAD FOR THAT DOG.
ARE WE GO AGAIN SO